welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka [ __ ]
Greyson and all it takes is Robert
Pattinson to do one joke and everybody
starts losing their minds you may have
recently seen the new interview with GQ
in which he talks about his process for
the upcoming film in the article he
talks about how he's not been working
out during the lockdown and naturally as
you'd expect the internet took it really
well know that they did in that thought
they all had meltdowns now throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking down
the interview John Campea is reaction
everyone flipping out about John Campea
reaction and then maybe flipping out
ourselves I don't know we'll see how I
feel there may be some spoilers here in
regards to the film so if you don't
anything rune then I highly recommend
that you turn off now make sure you
subscribe to the channel to never miss a
video and please drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy what may actually be some
level-headed coverage and all of this
without the way though thank you for
clicking this and let's get into our
breakdown of the Batman interview okay
so this interview dropped on Tuesday and
the main reason that I didn't cover it
instantly is because I just dropped a
Batman video a couple of hours before
and I hate doing the same topic twice in
a row I also wanted to see what the
internet reaction to the piece would be
and needless to say they didn't
disappoint me we need to talk about what
was said before breaking it all down but
yeah there's been some hilarious
reactions to this that have made me die
from laughing more than a joker victim
now the interview itself starts off with
this incredible quote by Pattinson and
I'll try it I try and do the voice but
you know we're not exactly the most
talented channel on YouTube anyway
Pattinson yesterday I was just googling
I was going on YouTube to see how the
microwave pasta GQ then went on to say
that's not a thing - which Pattinson
replied put it put it in a bowl and
microwave it that is how to microwave
pasta and also it really really isn't a
thing it's really actually quite
revolting but I mean who would have
thought that it actually made it taste
disgusting
GQ then asked how he was surviving and
this is where the interview descended
into complete troll territory
I'm essentially on a meal plan for
Batman thank God I don't know what I'd
be doing other than that but I mean yeah
other than I can survive
I'll have oatmeal with like vanilla
protein powder on it and I'll barely
even mix it up it's extraordinarily easy
like I eat out of cans and stuff I
literally put Tabasco inside a tuna can
and just eat it out the can it's weird
but my preferences are that just sort of
eat it like a wild animal like out of a
trash can from here he was asked what
workout he was doing and this is the
thing that got everyone worked up seeing
his reply he said my personal trainer
left me with a ball a single weight and
a sincere plea to used both but I'm
ignoring her I think if you're working
out all the time you're part of the
problem you set a precedent no one was
doing this in the 70s even James Dean he
wasn't exactly ripped when filming
Twilight the one time they told me to
take my shirt off I think they told me
to put it back on again but Batman is
Batman zoe kravitz is training five
times a week but literally I'm barely
doing anything and then the interviewer
said that he just sighed so basically he
jokingly said that he wasn't working out
and then John Campea did his video on
this now careful kiddies there's bad
language in this clip so if you're
watching this leave the room for like 15
seconds or something but keep playing
because okay the ad revenue Robert
Downey jr. money I mean let's not let's
not get carried away he's not making
Robert Downey jr. money but still when a
studio is paying you millions of dollars
and hiring you nutritionists and hiring
you trainers and all they say to you is
hey how about you know while you're
locked at home and not doing anything
think maybe you could listen weights
think maybe you could work out a little
bit no I'm Robert Pattinson [ __ ]
I don't do that screw you I don't have
time for that I can't be bothered with
that what the [ __ ] else are you doing
you [ __ ] you're sitting at home
during a pandemic
you're making mac and cheese is nothing
else to do this company's paying you
millions of dollars hired you
professionals to help you whatever and
nobody's expecting you to be a 250-pound
bodybuilder nobody's expecting that all
we want is your commitment and effort
and Rob what this says to me as a fan
what this says to me as a fan is that he
does not have the respect for the
character he does not have the respect
for the company that is paying him
millions of dollars Rob he is getting
paid more money to do this movie than
almost everybody watching this show is
gonna make in their entire lifetimes
he's making more money doing this one
movie than most of us individuals either
participating in the show or watching
the show will ever make in their
lifetimes and all they are asking him to
do is pick up a [ __ ] dumbbell show
some commitment show some effort honor
the fans of the character honor the
studio that's paying you he'll honor the
character itself all were asking for is
your effort and all working out is Rob
is effort you're never gonna look like
Hugh Jackman but you know what give us
the best version physically as the
presence of Batman that you can the
whole video is half an hour long but
it's pretty much that ran for 30 minutes
though I will say that he does actually
have some good points in there from time
to time now people are kind of jumping
on Pattinson but I just don't think that
they get the joke Pattinson has been
completely trolling interviewers for a
while now and even as far back as 2011
Pattinson was making up stuff just to
annoy people this is actually a really
good story that he made up about a clown
dying when he went to see the circus you
know I was thinking during the
introduction when I was a kid and that's
a long time ago but you know the kids my
age boys my age I wanted to be baseball
players or they wanted to run away and
join the circus
it's a very different time did you have
any of those dreams as a kid running
away and joining the circus no the first
thing I went to a star because somebody
died
I'm not letting that go how did the
clown die
it's little car exploded the junk car
exploded on him did that kind of ruin
the circus for you it wasn't like my
parents had to like littered everybody
ran out it was terrifying for people who
didn't didn't read the book that this
movie is based on tell me a little about
Jacob so I guess he will be killing the
Joker in this trilogy so he's jokes my
jokes aren't as good as him
now clearly campy I did get off on the
wrong foot here and completely
misinterpreted the interview I'm
actually gonna jump to his defense
slightly here and that I think he was
successfully trolled by Pattinson and
got triggered because of it but that
doesn't make him a bad guy now the
internet is also in a meltdown of a
Campea going into a meltdown so here's
me having a meltdown over people having
a meltdown over campy having a meltdown
and at the moment it's just one big
meltdown people are calling Campea a
disgrace saying he shouldn't be doing
videos and so on but at the end of the
day the guy just took some text that he
read the wrong way and had a bad
reaction to it I'm sure we've all been
the past received text messages from
people we know like we actually know
them in real life that we've taken out
of context and flipped out on him over
cambia doesn't know Pattinson and a
doubt he's really followed the actor
that much in interviews because if he
had he'd know that he just likes to push
buttons and is purposely agitating
people because it's funny to see their
reaction I really think that is what's
happened here but at the end of the day
whether he thinks Pattinson is going to
be a good or bad Batman that's
completely his opinion none of us have
seen the film it hasn't even been filmed
so all opinions at the moment should be
seen purely as speculation I'm very
excited for the movie but if someone
says that it's gonna be bad I just have
to let them think that because it's
their opinion you know what's as bad as
John Campea having a meltdown over
Robert Pattinson having a meltdown over
John Campea having a meltdown over
Robert Pattinson the performance of
Pattinson will speak for itself
godless of what is said in an interview
or not he's an actor he's paid to betray
a role that's different to his
personality I think the majority of
British people reading this interview
will understand the context of it and
get the sarcastic tone and it's very
much laced with the British sense of
humor that may not translate that well
overseas that doesn't mean anyone having
a meltdown over it is a bad guy
overall I will say what Campea said was
wrong and that he misinterpreted the
interview but that doesn't mean that his
heart's in the wrong place he's clearly
very passionate about the character and
just wants to see a Batman on the screen
that does justice to his rich history
I'm exactly the same as Campea and I
want to see Pattinson do well in the
role but I'm also ready to scrutinize
her if he messes up however where I'm
different is that I understand that this
was a joke interview so I'm not angry i
Pattinson for saying what he was saying
I think we all knew in advance that this
Batman wasn't really going to be a
meathead anyway this is a year two
storyline in which Batman has recently
returned to Gotham and he's now trying
to build his Legend through taking down
low-level thugs and criminals in Batman
law he spent a lot of time training
abroad and building his mind and
abilities so he didn't really have the
time to work out non-stop in the gym
upon returning to Gotham and having
gained the knowledge that he needed to
he was able to them focus on his body
and this is where he increased in size
over the years and until he was about 40
now Pattinson already is in good shape
which we've seen from when he's been
running and training he's not henry
cavill size but he doesn't need to be
this is just a guy starting out and we
have to remember that filming also
doesn't start for a while now on the
Batman it's not due to release until
October next year so there's still
plenty of time to get into shape he's
also wearing a costume that will be
covering how he looks Ben Affleck came
back for reshoots for Justice League and
when he was in costume you couldn't
really tell that he hadn't been training
all that much it's amazing what they can
do with costumes these days for example
Zachary Levi or is it Zachary Levi
anyway hey Shazam look is a lot of
padding and though he's in good shape
the costume also box him up a lot gal
gadot was pregnant while shooting Wonder
Woman and if the costume designers want
you to look a certain way they can
easily make it so therefore this
man we'll look exactly how the creative
team wants him to Henry Cavill could
have even been bulked up beyond what he
is and I don't think he would need to
work out as much as he does but maybe he
just enjoys doing it there the guy seems
to be in good shape so he probably would
be doing it regardless now that might
not work with Pattinson and yeah I very
much have faith that he's going to be in
the perfect shape for the character that
he's playing now whether you think
cambia is right or wrong and i don't
know if i pronounce Campea right or
wrong just take all these interviews
with a pinch of salt
the creative team are having fun whilst
being bored and locked down and they're
deliberately drumming a press for the
movie by putting things out there and
letting people flip out what can be a
did isn't a good look but all he really
did is take something out of context and
then go on a rant I'm going on a run now
pretty much about his rant but this is
all our opinions and it shouldn't ruin
the film for you if you're excited for
it everyone just needs to take a step
back and just chill out for a second
cambia did have some really good takes
in the whole video and it wasn't all bad
so yeah just let the guy live he's just
a fan as I'm sure everyone watching this
is it's a shame that on social media
this is all that everyone's talking
about right now in regards to the movie
and I didn't really want to cover it but
hey it's Batman using a hat - this is
just my opinion and if you disagree
that's completely fine - we will see
when the movie comes out and even then
there will be people that like it and
people that don't just prepare yourself
for that yeah obviously I loved hear
your thoughts on the entire situation so
comment below and let me know if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out a
breakdown of the recent Andy Serkis
interview on the movie it's not as angry
as this video so yeah go and have some
fun you want to support the channel from
is a little it's 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at Definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep a delay with heavy spoilers
so hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]